peu
l'ordinateur s'installe chaque jour de
plus en plus dans notre vie quotidienne
ainsi que nous prenions le métro le
train ou bien l'avion c'est lui qui
règle le trafic et veille sur notre
sécurité
bientôt ils nous sortira des
embouteillages et au train où vont les
choses on peut se demander quels seront
les domaines de notre existence qui lui
échappe con oui cette machine car ce
n'est qu'une machine va prendre une
telle place dans notre société qu'on
parle volontiers de révolution signe des
temps elle a déjà son salon le sicop
sicop cela signifie salon de
l'informatique de la communication et
l'organisation de bureau c'est en
quelque sorte une gigantesque foire à
l'ordinateur unique au monde par son
ampleur le sicop permet de prendre la
température du marché et cette année
elle fut particulièrement élevé outre
une nouvelle gamme d'ordinateurs
présenté par le plus grand constructeur
mondial
la prolifération des matériels
périphériques fut la tendance marquante
[Musique]
c'est ce dernier point qui va retenir
notre attention
en effet comment ces machines vont-elles
bouleverser notre vie mais déjà qu'est
ce qu'un périphérique
bien qu'il faille se méfier des
comparaisons entre l'homme et la machine
une animation ne fera mieux comprendre
leurs droits grâce à nos organes des
sens nous recevons constamment des
informations sur le milieu qui nous
entoure ces sensations sont captés et
acheminés vers le cerveau par les nerfs
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
si nous supprimons tous ses organes
il ne nous reste qu'un cerveau incapable
de rien faire en quelque sorte un
cerveau dans un bocal
et bien pour l'ordinateur c'est la même
chose pour travailler doit recevoir de
l'homme des informations grâce en
quelque sorte à des organes des sens
place et à sa périphérie et que l'on
appelle les périphériques ainsi grâce à
ces appareils comme ce clavier de
machines on peut communiquer avec
l'ordinateur
regardez ce monstre s'il est capable
d'effectuer un million d'opérations par
seconde de prévoir le temps il ne doit
sa puissance pour informations qu'on lui
fournit supprimer les il ne pourra rien
faire il ne sera qu'un agrégat de file
en somme une quincaillerie comme disent
les américains
mais tout de même une quincaillerie de
luxe comme vous l'imaginez communiquer
avec un tel engin ne va pas sans
problème car il faut bien le dire la
machine ne comprend pas grand chose tout
juste des 0 et des 1
alors au début on lui a parlé petit
[ __ ] avec des trous dans des cartes ou
des bandes
[Musique]
pour que l'ordinateur nous répondent de
façon intelligible et non pas par des
trous on lui a appris à écrire la
machine afin de faciliter encore ce
dialogue avec l'homme
on lui a appris à lire votre écriture
grâce à ce lecteur optique
il s'est mis aussi au dessin et l'humour
ne lui fait pas peur
regardez avec quelle aisance il dessine
le profil d'une autoroute
il n'y manque que le gazon
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il sait aussi dessiner les cartes
météorologiques et pour être dans le
vent il s'est mis à la télévision voilà
un aperçu des périphériques
d'ordinateurs seulement dans cet échange
d'informations entre l'homme et la
machine
il ne faut jamais oublier que ce qui
domine c'est le temps comme la machine
travaille à une vitesse prodigieuse
il ne faut pas qu'elles attendent les
données ce qui lui convient le mieux
c'est tout ce qui est magnétique lire
sur disque ou bandes et son rêve
alors au lieu de perforer une carte on
écrit maintenant directement les données
sur bande
[Musique]
regardez avec quelle rapidité on établit
votre dossier lors de l'achat d'une
voiture oui c'est cette couleur tous les
renseignements sont enregistrées sur
cette bande aussitôt lu par l'ordinateur
[Musique]
voici un autre exemple de périphériques
que nous rencontrons tous les jours et
oui c'est un ordinateur qui délivre
votre billet de métro
[Applaudissements]
c'est encore lui qui le lie
[Musique]
vous voulez retirer de l'argent
eh bien rien de plus facile une carte
magnétique un numéro de code et
l'ordinateur fait le reste
ces périphériques que vous venez de voir
vous les connaissez déjà mais grâce au
téléphone on leur donne en quelque sorte
une autre dimension
l'information peut alors être saisis sur
place n'importe où fini les pertes de
temps et les papiers regarder avec
quelle facilité on va retenir une place
d'avion
bien que le bureau soit à paris
l'ordinateur est à rome
et il tient à jour à chaque instant la
liste des vols ainsi que celle des
passagers
autre exemple l'odf vous voulez
l'installation d'un compteur bleu et
cela finit toujours par la même phrase
repasser dans quelques jours
bien et bien avisé de faire ça tout de
suite
alors ça c'est plus valable maintenant
je vais chercher votre aussi à
l'ordinateur
ainsi grâce à l'ordinateur votre dossier
est immédiatement accessible et on peut
y inscrire toute nouvelle modification
c'est là la grande révolution de
l'informatique ainsi grâce à son
étonnante rapidité sa prodigieuse
mémoire cette machine va bouleverser
notre vie et peut-être les enfants
apprendront ils bientôt son histoire
[Musique]
l'homme vit que cela était bon alors
compter sur ses doigts pour ne pas
l'oublier deuxième jour comme il n'avait
pas assez de toi
il est fatal le troisième jour fatigué
de côté lundi que la machine est telle
que les soies et la machine fille mais
le quatrième jour submergé par le
problème raison l'homme dit que
l'ordinateur soit et l'ordinateur comme
il vit que cela était bon
alors le 5ème jour l'homme qui est un
ordinateur 3,16 et multiplient
[Musique]
oui aujourd'hui ils sont cent mille
mais dans cinq ans leur nombre a doublé
[Musique]
faisons maintenant un saut dans le temps
et plaçons nous dans cinq dix ou quinze
ans il est tout d'abord la banque vous
voulez retirer de l'argent
eh bien rien de plus facile votre compte
apparaîtra aussitôt sur l'écran vous
pourrez ainsi vous présenter à n'importe
quel agent s'est retiré la somme que
vous voudrez sans aucune formalité mais
après tout aurons nous encore besoin
d'argent
fini cet engin une carte et une
étiquette magnétique glisser dans ce
lecteur connecté à un ordinateur feront
la faire votre compte sera aussitôt
débiter et la comptabilité du magasin
mises à jour ainsi que l'état des stocks
mais sans argent que deviendront nos
clochard et bien ils se mettront à
l'heure de l'ordinateur
une mini cassette enregistrera le
montant porté sur votre carte magnétique
[Applaudissements]
de chez vous vous pourrez aussi
d'interroger la machine par exemple pour
consulter votre compte en banque
et quand vous aurez le dos tourné vos
enfants vont s'en donner à coeur joie
[Musique]
napoléon est mort à sainte-hélène assez
rapidement l'informatique de biarritz si
vous pouviez pas voir ça pour après
demain
ah oui bah écoutez je vais demander à
l'ordinateur central permettez que je me
sers de téléphone
et oui ce sera le représentant de demain
cette valise est un périphérique reliés
par téléphone à l'ordinateur à l'aide du
clavier on enregistre plus ils sont
libres ou les informations que vous les
avoir pour demain matin si vous voulez
c'est tentant mais je voulais comme on
débat et que vous recommandez ça
[Musique]
voilà un aperçu du monde de demain et
peut-être regretterez vous le temps de
l'ordinateur romantique
[Musique]